foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
discussing a notoriously difficult spell
to cast the Patronus charm specifically
we'll be addressing all known patronuses
assigned to Harry Potter characters and
exploring what those Patronus animals
mean it was the Prisoner of Azkaban that
first introduced the idea of patronus's
spirit Guardians produced via the
complicated spell expecto patronum
expecto patronum is typically used to
ward off Dementors and in Fantastic
Beasts we are informed that the Patronus
is also used to ward off leatherfolds in
most circumstances the Patronus charm
will generally appear as a white Vapor
however in some instances when the witch
or wizard is talented enough expecto
patronum will produce a silvery white
animal shape which is known as a
corporeal Patronus the Patronus
represents hope happiness survival and
pure which is why it's so offensive to
Dementors and can also be used as a
Communications device a notable example
of this being when Snape used his
Patronus to guide Harry to The Sword of
Gryffindor in The Forest of Dean if you
asked any member of The Faculty at
Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and was a
dream they'd quickly tell you it's one
of the most difficult spells that a
wizard or wedge can cast even though
Harry managed to master it when he was
only 13 years old many other Wizards
didn't in fact it wasn't uncommon for
adult Wizards and witches to fail to
produce even a formless Patronus as
shameful as the thought might be so
today I thought we'd take a look at the
Historical records and track down every
single Patronus and their Caster from
The Wizarding World from the massive
woolly mammoth that Hadley Fleetwood
conjured to the boar of Ernie MacMillan
bear in mind that not everyone we know
has been able to cast a Patronus
successfully so you won't necessarily
see all your favorite characters on the
list let's get into it but before we
dive in I want to tell you a little bit
about today's sponsor expressvpn have
you ever gone to search for a show on
Netflix and not been able to find it
might have but here's the thing Netflix
has most shows and movies they're just
not available in all geographical
locations depending on where you live
Netflix is going to give you different
content that means you're paying for a
full subscription and only get access to
one part of their Library this is where
expressvpn comes in handy as with their
services you're able to instantly change
your geographical location and unlock
thousands of movies and shows you
wouldn't otherwise have access to they
have servers in 94 countries and they
offer Lightning Fast speeds so that you
can stream in HD quality with no
problems for example here I am
connecting to one of their servers in
turkey and accessing the Harry Potter
films are you guys familiar with them
these films are not currently accessible
in my location but with online resources
like this one we can see exactly where
we need to connect from in order to get
the movies we want expressvpn is a
service that I genuinely use all the
time as it helps to protect my data and
gives me full access to streaming
services online find out how you can get
three months of expressvpn for free by
visiting expressvpn.com Harry Potter
Theory or clicking the link in the
description below thanks again to
expressvpn for sponsoring the video 1.
androsy Invincible Andros the Invincible
was one of the earliest Wizards in all
of recorded history hailing from
Classical Greece Andros lived in a
darker time one of his possible peers
the evil wizard known as Harpo was the
very first to breed basilisks but Andros
would have been more than Mighty enough
to deal with such an enemy according to
the ancient texts Andros was powerful
enough to project a Patronus as large as
a giant 2. ileus Elias was another
ancient wizard from the depths of
History but unlike Andros the Invincible
Elias wasn't able to conjure a colossal
Patronus from the tip of his wand
instead his Patronus took on the form of
a tiny field mouse at first Elias's
fellow villagers laughed at the size of
his Patronus but after an evil dark
wizard named roxidian attacked and
Unleashed an army of Dementors elius's
tiny Mouse Patronus was the only thing
that could save them if you have a field
mouse Patronus you are probably a great
listener as well as very kind and caring
3. flavius Balby vlavius belbi a wizard
who was famous enough to Warrant his own
chocolate frog card could project a bull
or ox or Ram we're not actually sure
belbi only mentioned that his Patronus
had a pair of horns so it could have
been almost anything belby actually used
his Patronus in order to survive an
attack from a living shroud these dark
creatures preyed on Wizards and witches
4. Cho Chang during her time at Hogwarts
School of Witchcraft and was a dree long
before the Battle of Hogwarts and
Voldemort's death and Cho learned how to
conjure a Patronus as a member of
Dumbledore's Army she quickly studied
under Harry's leadership and managed to
give her Patronus a corporeal form a
swan if you have a swan Patronus it
signifies that you are loyal as well as
beautiful inside and out 5. at the
fourth Dumbledore Abba forth was the
younger brother of Albus Dumbledore the
legendary Headmaster of Hogwarts and the
only wizard that Lord Voldemort ever
feared compared to Albus it might be
tempting to dismiss abbeforeth's magical
abilities but AB was no slouch he was
able to conjure a Corporal Patronus
which was the mark of a skilled wizard
he took on the form of a goat and he
even used it to defend Harry once when
Dementors were on the hunt for him goats
are sweet loving creatures that mind
their own business so if you can cast a
goat as your Patron is then it's
possible that the same could be said of
you
6. Albus Dumbledore Wizards and witches
couldn't necessarily choose the form of
their Patronus and just like creatures
in the real world the forms of
patronuses seem to come in similar
Rarity dogs cats and horses were common
types of patronuses but the likes of
dragons Giants and mammoths were far
rarer but when it came to Albus
Dumbledore he possessed one of the
rarest patronuses of all a phoenix if
you are able to cast this Patronus it
signifies that you are a loyal friend
with quiet Inner Strength 7. Sheamus
Finnegan we often talk about the
Patronus charm as one of the most
difficult for any Wizard or wedge to
pull off but with so many members of
Dumbledore's Army able to project the
spell you can't help but Wonder was it
really that hard well all you have to do
is take a look at Sheamus Finnegan to
realize just how difficult a Patronus
could be during his time in Dumbledore's
Army he never quite managed to pull off
a fully formed one it was wasn't until
the Battle of Hogwarts that his Patronus
was given shape as a fox on the
battlefield those were the fox Patronus
are usually thought of as crafty devious
Sly and calculating but also wise
adaptable and loyal 8. Headley Fleetwood
Headley Fleetwood is a peculiar wizard
to say the least he doesn't appear in
any historical record except one and
there the writer glances over Fleetwood
sharing only that the wizard was able to
conjure a woolly mammoth as his Patronus
with such an incredibly large and rare
Patronus you'd think that Fleetwood
would have been one of the most powerful
wizards of his generation little is
known about those who cast the Patronus
in the form of a woolly mammoth as it's
exceedingly rare however this could
suggest that you yourself are a very
very unique individual 9. Hermione
Hermione Granger was one of the most
important members of Dumbledore's Army
and one of Harry Potter's closest allies
during his hunt to destroy Voldemort's
horcruxes just like Harry she was able
to produce a Patronus in the form of an
animal hers took on the shape of an
otter but as much as she hated to admit
it that particular spell was actually
quite hard for her to learn
otters are both fearless and naturally
curious and if you have this animal as
your Patronus then you probably have a
close-knit group of people in your life
that you're immensely loyal to 10. Harry
Potter Harry Potter's Patronus was
incredibly iconic which was both a good
and bad thing when Lord Voldemort
finally took control of the ministry his
death actors kept an eye out for Harry's
Patronus a mighty white stag that
certainly restricted Harry's ability to
defend himself from dark creatures but
the fact that Harry could so easily
project his Patronus also helped him
Inspire other students at Hogwarts to
join Dumbledore's Army a lot can be said
of individuals who produce a stag as
their Patronus generally individuals
with this Patronus are influential
leaders who deeply care about the
well-being of others additionally these
individuals are confident in themselves
and vehemently stand up for their
beliefs 11. James Potter just like his
son James Potter's Patronus took on the
form of a white stag when James was
wandering around the grounds at Hogwarts
the Stag was also the form he chose to
take whenever he transfigured as an
animagus the fact that he and his son
shed the same Patronus was one of the
few Comforts that Harry had during the
increasingly dark years at Hogwarts with
only second-hand stories from folks like
Hagrid and Dumbledore Harry often sought
a deeper connection to his deceased
parents and he found that in part when
he discovered that he and his father
both produced Stags 12. Luna Lovegood
even though producing a corporeal
Patronus was a tough feeds Luna Lovegood
certainly seems like she'd be one to do
so her father xenophilius Lovegood was a
wildly eccentric wizard but even he
managed to produce a Patronus although
one that was too weak to take on a shape
Luna on the other hand could project a
stunning white hair whenever she cast
the spell the ham Patronus is
representative of someone who is patient
and intelligent these individuals are
also usually timid but handle life's
obstacles with poise witches and wizards
with this Patronus adapt well to most
situations and understand that the
difficulties in life make them stronger
13. Ernie MacMillan
Ernie MacMillan might not be a wizard
you're too familiar with he was sorted
into Hufflepuff house the very same year
that Harry Potter first came to Hogwarts
and was sorted into Gryffindor
throughout the years he lived alongside
the boy who lived and sometimes even
acted out against Harry at one point
Ernie even accused Harry of being the
heir of Slytherin but after his second
year at Hogwarts his suspicions mostly
subsided and he went on to fight bravely
at the Battle of Hogwarts where his
Patronus a terrifying bouldering boar
ran through the Death Eater ranks those
with this Patronus can Channel their
passion into achieving their dream
they embody strength Independence and
power 14. Minerva McGonagall along with
Albus Dumbledore and Severus Snape
Minerva McGonagall was among the most
skilled spellcasters and the entire
Hogwarts faculty and that was shown in
her Patronus as well just like James
Potter Minerva was an animagus she was
able to change her body into the shape
of a cat and that was the same exact
form that her Patronus took on her
Patronus was famously used to warn the
students at Hogwarts about the incoming
attack in the moments before their final
battle against Voldemort individuals
with a cat Patronus are often watchful
Guardians who show Fierce loyalty to
their friends and family this sounds
exactly like McGonagall to me 15.
Dolores Umbridge it might surprise you
to know but even Dolores Umbridge was
capable of casting a Patronus however
this is a bit odd as Dolores was a dark
witch and history has told us what
happens to those who attempt to Cronus
without a pure heart even stranger is it
umbridge's evil nature was compounded by
her possession of one of Voldemort's
horcruxes when she displayed her
Patronus a cat I've made a separate
video discussing why Dolores could cast
a Patronus at all so go and check that
out later if you're curious 16. Lily
Potter Harry's mother Lily Potter had a
Patronus that perfectly matched her
husbands Lily could conjure a doe just
as James could conjure a stag it was
rare to produce such a fitting match
which makes Harry's parents and Harry
himself even more of the Curiosity the
ability to cast a dope Patronus means
your gentle nurturing and will stop at
nothing to keep those you love safe 17.
Severus Snape zebras Snape's Patronus
was one of the most heartbreaking of
them all he loved Harry's mother so much
that even his Patronus took on the form
of hers a doe a symbol of his devotion
Snape famously cast the spell in front
of Dumbledore to show just how much she
loved her and for those that ever
doubted professor's name to Legions to
Dumbledore his ability to project such a
pure Patronus tells you all you'll need
to know if he were an average Death
Eater his wand would have exploded into
a million pests and his body would have
been consumed but that never happened to
Snape 18. symposia rule symposia rule
was a witch whose Patronus took the form
of a ladybird or ladybug it's worth
noting that despite the minuscule size
of this Patronus it was still extremely
powerful if you have this Patronus
people might underestimate you but you
also consistently prove yourself to be
trustworthy strong and reliable 19.
Kingsley shacklebolds Kingsley shackle
boats Patronus is a lynx a medium-sized
wild cat with Tufts of black hair air on
the tips of their ears large padded Paws
for walking on snow and long whiskers on
the face though kingsley's Patronus is
confirmed to be a links in the novels
it's worth noting that the films did not
convey this accurately in the films
kings's Patronus appears during Bill and
fleur's wedding announcing the downfall
of the ministry in this scene his
patronas simply appears as a
non-descript ball of light perhaps more
closely resembling a non-corporeal
Patronus if you have this Patronus
you're a unique individual that people
tend to love 20. nymphadora Tonks the
Patronus of nymphadora Tonks is
particularly interesting in that it
changed as a result of events in her
life specifically her love for Remus
Lupine before meeting Remus her Patronus
took the form of a hair and after the
pair came together it turned into a wolf
which happened to be the same Patronus
as Remus this was a true reflection of
her love for him if your Patronus is a
wolf then it's a sign that you should
trust your instincts as you are most
often right about situations 21. Remus
Lupine though Remus would often cast a
non-corporeal Patronus and not be more
advanced corporeal version this was not
any kind of a reflection of his magical
ability you see although Remus could
produce a Corporal Patronus he chose not
to why well Remus Lupine was a
lycanthrope meaning he could transform
into a werewolf and it just so happened
that his Patronus reflected his
transformative stage resembling a wolf
due to remus's shame of his condition he
chose not to reveal his Patronus animal
when casting the powerful spell in 22
Arthur Weasley Arthur Weasley patriarch
of the Weasley Clan had a weasel
Patronus it's first seen when he sends a
message on Harry's 17th birthday and
seen again when he sends his Patronus to
gremled place to inform Harry Ron and
Hermione that the Weasleys were safe it
doesn't surprise me at all that the
Whimsical Weasley father ended up with a
Patronus that fits his family name so
well individuals with a weasel Patronus
are often spontaneous playful and
intuitive however they're also a bit
chaotic 23. Ginny Weasley Ginny Weasley
the Weasley daughter and Harry's later
wife had a horse Patronus it's extremely
fitting that Ginny who is such a free
spirit would have a wild horse as her
Patronus individuals with this Patronus
are often deeply passionate people
24 Ron Weasley Ron Weasley's Patronus
was a Jack Russell Terrier a fiercely
loyal and protective breed of dog this
makes perfect sense if you consider
Ron's role as Harry's loyal best friend
fun fact the first time I took the
Wizarding World Patronus quiz I got a
Jack Russell Terrier individuals with
this Patronus can be stubborn when they
don't get their way which are always
loyal and fearless when it comes to
protecting their loved ones 25. friend
George Weasley though the Patronus
animal of the Weasley twins wasn't
revealed in the films it was revealed by
Rowling on Twitter after the fact it
also shouldn't surprise you that these
brothers who shared everything also
shared a Patronus animal the Patronus
conjured by the Weasley twins took the
shape of a magpie a small but loud
crow-like bird to cool someone a magpie
is a reference to their boisterous
Behavior so it's only fitting that their
Patronus would fit
attention-seeking nature Rowling had
this to say in reference to the Twins
and their Magpie Patronus we have a
saying about them in the UK one for
sorrow two for joy as you might know she
wrote plus their talkative thieves 26.
raxidian if there was one rexidian would
be the poster boy for why you shouldn't
try to cast a Patronus without a pure
heart rexidian was an ancient dark
wizard that used his dark magic and army
of Dementors to attack a Wizarding
Village however its efforts were
thwarted when Ilyas who we mentioned
earlier used his small But Mighty Mouse
Patronus to Ward rexidian and his
Dementors off
after witnessing his Dementors being
taken out by ileus's Mouse Patronus
rexidian decided it would be a good idea
to cast a Patronus himself but this
would be his downfall enraged rexidian
decided to enter The Fray himself and
tried to summon a Patronus to ward off
ilius's mouse however he failed to
remember that only the pure of Hearts
can produce a Patronus and thus for the
first time in history it was revealed
what happens when a competent but
unworthy Wizard or wedge attempts the
spell maggots shot out rexidian's wand
and quickly devoured him as they
engulfed his entire body in 27 Neville
despite Neville's attendance at
Dumbledore's Army meetings he still had
an exceedingly difficult time casting a
Patronus though he was able to master
the basic a non-corporeal Patronus he
couldn't quite get the hang of producing
one with an animal form I like to think
that if he could produce a Corporal
Patronus then it would assume the form
of a toad an Ode to Trevor before we
continue I just want to mention that the
rest of the names on this layers to come
from extended law I.E Harry Potter games
like Hogwarts mystery Wizards unite
wonderbook book of spells Etc they may
not be characters that a lot of you are
familiar with but there are some pretty
interesting Patronus animals here 28.
Patricia rake pick Patricia rake pick
was a dark witch who tortured marula
snide with the cruciatus curse and
murdered Rowan Khana with the killing
curse but was still somehow able to cast
a Corporal Patronus in the form of a
lioness she first conjures her Patronus
in the Forbidden Forest in an effort to
Cast Away Dementors those with a line
Patronus often Brave and courageous able
to make sacrifices for the people that
they love and sometimes others in 29
Miriam rounds Madame Miriam Stroud is a
British witch and healer in the jaina
sticky Ward at Saint manga's Hospital
for Magical maladies and injuries her
Petronas took the form of a white swan
to commemorate the loss of her friend
and colleague Talbot Winger's mother who
was an unregistered animagus capable of
transforming into a white swan those who
produced this Patronus are thought to be
beautiful inside and out 30. Constance
Pickering Constance Pickering was a
Half-Blood witch who worked for the
British Ministry of magic and led the
statute of secrecy task force
interestingly Constance was able to
conjure a Patronus in the shape of a
unicorn this was a very rare achievement
as magical creatures don't commonly
appear as Patronus animals those who
produced this Patronus are said to be
pure of heart 31. Daniel page Daniel
page was a British half Band Wizard
appearing in Magic awakened who began
attending Hogwarts School of Witchcraft
and Wizardry in 2008 and Paige was able
to produce a Patronus in the shape of a
black cat
32 Lottie Turner Lottie Turner was aware
to attended Hogwarts School in 2008 and
could produce a Patronus in the shape of
a hummingbird those who produce a
hummingbird Patronus tend to be
free-spirited and seek to enjoy life to
its fullest however despite their small
stature they also have a tendency to
protect often standing up for their
loved ones
33 Cassandra Vol Cassandra Vol was a
witch who attended Hogwarts School in
2008 and could produce a Patronus in the
shape of a mink her Patronus form having
a connection to her last name is
reminiscent of Arthur Weasley's Patronus
being a weasel those with a mink
Patronus seek safe environments and
overall security
34 Colby Frey Colby Frey was a wizard
who attended Hogwarts School in 2008.
his Patronus took the form of a
crocodile crocodile symbolize patience
Primal energy and tradition having a
crocodile Patronus means you are
assertive and self-assured but not
overly showy 35. Fisher Frey Fisher
frame was a wizard who attended Hogwarts
School in 2008. his Patronus took the
form of a rhinoceros those with a
rhinoceros Patronus are Fierce Warriors
and certainly not afraid of a fight
however they also have quite a soft side
reserved for their family and friends
36. Ivy Warrington Ivy Warrington was a
half blood wedge who attended Hogwarts
School in 2008. her Patronus took the
form of a Pekingese a small dog this is
known to be very loyal kind and
affectionate 37. Robin thistlethwaite
Robin thistle weight was a witch who
attended Hogwarts School in 2008 her
Patronus took the form of a polar bear
similar to the rhinoceros those with a
polar bear Patronus our face in battle
but have a soft side reserved for loved
ones
38. Kevin Farrell Kevin Farrell was a
wizard who attended Hogwarts School in
2008. his Patronus took the form of a
hedgehog those were their Hedgehog
Patronus saw often particularly worried
about the well-being of themselves and
others and that concludes a list of all
known Harry Potter character patronuses
if you guys want a video on all possible
patronuses going through each and every
type of Patronus and what they mean then
like the video and leave a comment down
below to let me know additionally if you
want a video where I theorize on what
some popular Harry Potter character
patronuses might be then let me know
that as well until next time remember it
does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
[Music]